here's a white fella right here from
baton rouge louisiana let's hear it
i'm josh from pineville louisiana and i
have a kinder stinger for you
but first a backstory so i had to move
close to my mom she has early onset
alzheimer's amen brother those goofy
things
it all means well her heart is always in
the right place it's just
so she comes into my house
and she hands me this bag she's looking
all serious
and she's like josh i have something
very personal for you
and i want you to use it and i'm like
sweet i'm about to get a watch
maybe a journal
she hands me
a fake vagina amen bro with my
ex-girlfriend's name on it
she claims she doesn't remember her name
i didn't forget
[Laughter]
that which caused a big old mess just
powder everywhere
and some shaving cream with it wow
and she gave got me this water based
lube which is definitely being used
so king understand it should i use this
false vagina that my mom gave me
buzz buzz game go tigers
your tigers suck this year that's
another thing well
uh that's a little creepy yeah go and
use them
get get after a big boy no man i can't
you can't use a sex toy for your mother
but
that was that video was like two minutes
he also said at one point he was uh on a
dry spell
so see the mom's looking out the mom's
just like dude we gotta do something
yeah we just gotta get you started in
the right direction mm-hmm
well she don't she's it's not a it's not
a homosexual issue brandon
she's not saying the little man's
homosexual i didn't say that but the
right direction you're assuming
otherwise you give him a little bag of
weiner i know
i know she's she she's assuming he's not
homosexual
so she gave him that kind of flesh like
or maybe she's assuming that
she's trying to send him in that
direction is what i want like i just
don't know what's going on is that an
age what are you guys doing asian and
black community guys help us out here
if if somebody gives you a bag of dick a
bag of wiener puss
or whatever man somebody rolls up on you
you saw the video if somebody
showed up with a bag of sexual [ __ ] to
put your [ __ ] in
yeah how do you feel how do i feel i
mean [ __ ] i'm like thanks for the gift
really so yeah if your dad came in here
and had a bag of dicks you'd be cool
with it
oh i was thinking i was thinking the
vagina
the bag sorry guys i'm sorry for yelling
too no you're good
to understand i'm an outfielder dude we
have to raise our voice we have to
communicate
that's what i was thinking i was vibing
with you i know it's the color thing oh
dawg you know we the realest
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
amen bro praise god praise god [ __ ]
these white people
what else do you got nick no no we
didn't finish it
i went yeah if someone gave me a bag of
dicks i'd be like eat a dick
okay okay but if somebody gave you a uh
vagina a booty hole vagina or a booty
hole
they do that too if they gave me a
plastic vagina i was like i have a
girlfriend
and you hadn't and she didn't exist and
you hadn't had sex look at you bringing
out this hypothetical [ __ ]
yeah got my brain all [ __ ] up now man
hey i'm not gonna lie nick you've
probably
got it let's be real here nick knows his
way around like a
classic vegetable that's why he's like
but what if your girlfriend didn't exist
yeah what if it's like a really good one
a really fancy way
yeah i've definitely walked in when nick
was we were eating something up in the
microwave in here
and it wasn't food okay a couple months
ago his underwear was right here
all right why are your underwear hidden
in cat's [ __ ] seat though this guy's
got a king at her stinger
[Music]